One year ago,...
...an elite commando unit was sent to prison for a crime they didn't commit.
These men promptly escaped from a maximum security facility.
Today, still wanted by the government...
...they survive as soldiers for hire.
This is beyond nuts, boss.
It gets better.
Now we're talking.
You missed me?
'Cause I missed you!
If you have a problem,...
...if no one else can help...
...and if you can find them,...
It sucks to be you, homie.
You look like you got a real bad attitude.
...maybe you can hire...
I love it when a plan comes together.
...The A-Team.
What the hell is that?
If you look out on the right-hand side of the aircraft,...
...you'll notice that the right wing is on fire.